wait why is it wait no we beat these we
know we beat these no they're all locked
for me why are they locked why am I on a
boat in the middle of the ocean because
we are on our way to okay where the hell
is the next land at okay cool we are
welcome to it's an ice axe all right I
don't know okay I've forgotten how to
play really oh my god I don't get that
kind of it okay Kenan how'd you get past
the cannon I don't know man I don't know
how it fires fires real weird how the
cannon right am i right yeah the cannon
I don't know why or when it fires but it
fires very weirdly was kind of a dick
move I will acknowledge oh god there's a
meeting oh dear
guys I made it off the right side the
right side first and then you gotta hit
the wall above those spikes on the right
wall and then jump - across over the
other way wait I feel like you're
[ __ ] this up for me how do I bounce
higher I don't understand you
I got I got there you go there you guys
okay and then you just got a - jump over
this it's pretty see pretty easy yeah I
[Laughter]
got it you have to jump when you're at
the top you use your second jump in the
air not I know how to do it call it
quits
alright cool we're gonna call it quits
finish the level it froze me in the air
so I died where did you kill me I killed
you and also died see ya so RT so this
is just like a well-timed jump -
situation oh no how do you get how -
does it work wait okay how do you make
that oh oh hey it's not hard is it
really just a jump - yeah I made it
oh let's just lay down for a minute
[Laughter]
don't touch that
[ __ ] oh I know well that's my bad yeah
oh god damn it no [ __ ] door [ __ ]
just on my screen it's so sudden that
you slam you gotta go up on the wall
slide down while you're going left it's
easy so you jump over it to the right
side yeah and then you bounce okay got
it okay
also if you stay in this water too long
you die of froze cold yeah well I didn't
see that
guys wait there's a button yeah no oh
[ __ ] oh that's daddy
[Laughter]
don't make fun of me boy oh boy you want
me to go for it yeah [ __ ] you guys
jumping over the Springer were you
jumping on the wall above the spring and
then dropping down I was jumping over it
I was using the wall to get over it safe
over the spring and the other just drop
down from the wall go left
all right good job everybody well done
you're gonna try this oh boy goodbye
there's a secret [ __ ] I trust the fart
noise made it nice go go for it
you just got go under that thing to the
left no not what oh oh wait what oh god
damn it okay
gosh it got okay okay okay all right
this doesn't make any sense top wall
jump oh I see
is a lot easier than the way I was going
why didn't I go that way for you know
I'm so inconsistent with underneath
- and then wall jump up oh [ __ ] there's
no way out it's gotta be no I know I
just keep dive bombing headfirst into
spikes be in the Loser Club
so you gotta like like and then nope
that's not it
no just that's smart
okay all right you don't yeah that that
makes more sense you know you've got
this Bob jump jump
you forgot to jump [ __ ] dammit just
help me yeah did you I spent the first
half of it going the wrong way
is there secret down there or something
cuz I didn't see it no don't go back
there was no no no don't go back oh no
I'm going jump hey made it I'm going for
it oh it's ice oh boy it's ice
I can wait where do we go from here
good question I'm going down there's a
button oh [ __ ] you're right I'm going
for it I'm going for it aah
oh all right I see what you guys look at
that look at that there's a button right
under me right here where do you see the
button do you see the button to see it
huh big boy shoe boy huh oh [ __ ] oh you
into the barrels jump out of the water
there's a little platform oh you're
right the barrels is the way Oh get out
there all right do the button thing Oh
team trying to [ __ ] you wreck until you
try to [ __ ] me continue trying to [ __ ]
you have to fall off right ere jump the
wall jump wall jump and then - left walk
off to your right and then use your air
jump to get on that wall and then oh
yeah then you oh there you go oh oh
close that was it though what do your -
it's not long dashing I'm not long
jumping anymore get over this how do I
get over this it's gonna die now long -
anymore there we go well not like that
it just uh is it just a perfect jump
whoopsies oh no that's not a thing is it
I don't know man here we go use me
you're gonna have to jump I guess can i
if i do it i can jump yeah here jump on
me maybe someone who's better at the
jumping aspect should do that and I'll
be a doormat trade me spots okay all
right here we go through the gaps in
those two flowers here watch oh I see
what you're saying no that was too jumpy
I see I see what you're saying is this
the only way to do this math right okay
all right okay it's fine this got really
hard oh I made it
oh [ __ ] oh my god just the tip spam
rushing is what we need to do I'm first
this time look at me okay what killed me
yes come on No
oh my god that was real fun oh all right
that's I'm going for it
holy [ __ ] I made it
holy [ __ ] did you see that I'm here
again wait this is not the exit sorry
this is not the exit there's a button in
the water can you jump on the snowballs
there's a button in the water click oh
you can jump on this show Jesus okay top
left is that top left it open huh where
I don't see I wasn't looking oh I see
where it opened up
I see where it opened up I'm not gonna
tell you guys we can actually put a coin
for this by the way whatever man I'll
call you back and get a coin huh you
guys see that silly [ __ ] yes Oh God
no up guys I got a problem I met the
exit I missed the exit
no that's not the exit eggs is over here
over here
[Music]
[ __ ] criminy Christmas guys guys guys
another spike sir I meant to tell you
about it yeah sorry about that man
real sorry [ __ ] why can't I do the
snowballs
that's why [ __ ] dick Wow
mark do you have to jump on the snowball
of you don't you don't you dare we don't
have a coin who cares about the coin
wait you're literally the only human
being that cares about the coin we're
gonna find it we're going back walk you
don't have to use the snowball I did it
without the snowball you just have to
wall jump and then jump all that's
that's easy okay I don't know why
thought to do it as cool as possible
yeah I thought okay what oh no I think
we should make way to it we either do it
it's fun to watch do it wait no no you
have to do it wait you won't see see
it's fun when you're the person who
hasn't done it and the other two are
like do it yeah Wow wait why why would
you do that fair enough I guess do it
wait do it you got it wait [ __ ] oops
do it Bob Bob
[Laughter]
there were spikes on there as gonna tell
you all right whatever just sacrifice
yourself I think I know where the secret
was I think it was wait let me see three
don't go there go kit - it was - I think
there was a secret I remember seeing the
I thing the I do you know the the secret
I you guys buddy we're gonna back that
up you see the the the switch up there
the sproingy above us there's um there's
an i there's an i there so there's gotta
be some secret to it right maybe you
guys were right about opes ladies behind
the spring did any of you go was all
right I need to go behind the spring on
that one
no I don't think so ah nothing I was
yeah I was over there I didn't
understand what you meant I guess all
right then I have no idea
isn't that I the secret thing though
isn't that it I thought no wait yes wait
let me see if it does something else so
you think maybe maybe what the [ __ ] your
wizard
that's easy man no it's not [ __ ] it's
very easy to do anything directly into
the spikes did you do anything else not
that I see oh okay I never even got up
there before so I'm unaware of this
wait on the far left yes you see the
tree in the Snowman right above it
there's a little ice cube with an eye
symbol on it Oh No Wade's got this no
okay
just dash in there like this you gotta
go under it bro
guys I've discovered spikes that don't
kill you in this game huh those do so
you just got a I don't know if I get I
got it's it's gold for me I don't know
why I got hidden Gold's on mine and said
it hang on wait let me let me get it too
I don't even see it on my screen anymore
so do we have to finish the level
yeah I think so I spotted it guys I did
something yeah why do I gotta do it I
don't know it only ever basic gold or
gold for you ball sacks you know there's
some friend
Oh God darts out of a dirty dirty dirt
we gotta push the button we push the
button and then what where where does
the button open top left you see the
Snowman no there's a snowman above the
ones when you balls
I appreciate that can I do one of these
[Laughter]
all right I'll be the first one to like
this place got it got it
[ __ ]
there we go and what's over here where
am i oh you don't even need that [ __ ]
don't jump there definitely don't jump
whatever you do Wow all right mark do I
do this skill oh yeah oh yeah don't go
okay go this one it's fine it's fine
it's fine
okay okay I think we fall here just stop
being such a poop we're just good jump
on the train damn it good screw are you
jumping on the train
Oh No why weren't you jumping on the
train I made it oh [ __ ]
guys I made it go up now oh nice
tight tight tight don't go don't go
there I just really wanted to once I saw
we need to climb up here no you don't go
up there what did you think I was saying
when I said don't go up here wants to
kill you or something I don't know I
didn't want you to die holy [ __ ] your
wizard mark I know do you have to dodge
the spikey now not like that it's gonna
take a nice L on that one okay see ya
okay
oh god damn it what the [ __ ] is this
[ __ ] friend [ __ ] it's the top easier
oh I don't know I was distracted oh it
actually is much easier to do that I see
did it alright so you like this and you
go haha got it got it got it got it
don't do that I know you do then why'd
you do it I think I understand but I
messed it up okay I've got this guy's
here we go dream team in just through
the air on my screen like a god damn
tricks wizard you guys remember the
earnest like goes to prison movies all
I'm hearing right now is earnest
actually gotten close to the
[Laughter]
stay away from me so much wait it'd be
fine if you were actually making it with
these douche bag moves of yours well
okay this is gonna be the one what I
made this like distractedly accidentally
once a long time ago it would be fine if
we didn't have an intentional sabotage
coming with us I'm doing a good job
performance review yeah it's me Whittier
walk goddamnit this yes look who's up
here now boss mark it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine
no word - I think you did it wrong mati
Josh will be waiting you're waiting I
see I see
God white [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay all right if we can't get this it's
just gonna be sad so I'm gonna really
try on this one is my journal
why [ __ ] there's a strategy and then
there's my way Oh Bob see if you could
do it oh never mind it stop it stop I
guess I'm here now do I go out this way
please leave this play oh no where do we
go out I don't know man not that way I
don't where to go there like the whole
time I think okay guys no carts anymore
so how do we get out laughing number he
say safe number six
oh I see no this spikes the end oh I
don't want to hey this way whoa no that
was easy actually how the [ __ ] did you
just do that
I just Walt don't I don't know if it'll
okay I did all I was oh like that okay I
understand
you know 90% of the noises you make
don't make me laugh catch me off-guard
okay
I'm very close guys yeah you just jump
across could you just go down here again
why would you think the barrels would be
bad
are you PewDiePie from 2012 what yeah
don't don't try me
don't try anyway I told you not to drive
me you try me hey I'm here hey what's up
douche bags I'm the furthest whoa okay
[ __ ] yeah
Oh God oh dear there's nothing there
spikes there all right so you wanna just
jump - avoid the snowballs sure yeah I
see that now
well that's not what you wanted you made
it guys there's one more obstacle but I
think I'm good wait a minute
I spy with my little eye a little bit of
a secret yeah yeah yeah don't you see
down there I see it down under - water
oh [ __ ] that's nice oh no that's kinda
there's no I just ended okay I was very
afraid I would have jumped right on that
spike right there my fingers hurt Oh
suck your fingers pinkies in the mouth I
really don't know what that's doing is
it it's kind of auto-tune it's just
shitty auto-tune your shitty auto-tune
wait I was waiting for a reason but you
know it's all good I just like to go for
it they know that about you we if
there's anyone among us as a go-getter
it's you Wade oh [ __ ] dude thank you for
the boost God got you no don't go oh no
oh here wait that was intentional what
did I do I didn't do anything to you
that was intentional what was
intentional I didn't do anything to you
I made you all suck oh you are awful I
feel like these snowballs should be
doing something but they're not there's
a secret somewhere here
keep your eyes peeled I tend to agree
with the man
why is it my fault because you were
standing here at the edge told you I
said there's a secret keep your eyes out
eyes out but I had to watch the woodies
I'll watch your woody hey I made it up
top what's up with no one cares Bob just
between me and Wayde buddy now take my
hand a long-dead this is my top platform
okay that's not the correct answer no oh
got it don't why are you like this
[ __ ] garbage bah all right guess
who's back at the top [ __ ]
just me no you just know you just drift
watch yeah then you get out it's not
just [ __ ] I've done bad guys okay watch
this watch this
what's this you go up here you go in
here you push and then you come here and
then you come up here and then you go oh
my god oh dear hey all easy all easy oh
god no not a snowball's [ __ ] why would I
have to jump off of a snowball no okay I
did okay does anybody see a secret just
like a Hey look out kind of thing you
know Bob's got this hi all right Bob you
just got jump off a snowball oh really
is that that's it that's the solution is
that yeah yeah I don't even see
snowballs snowballs are Dee spawning
what is this I don't know about that
that's the - button [ __ ] I just I sell
each pulled the right trigger happen
okay I'll just go then do it right there
yeah the snowballs were like D spawning
on my screen it was weird there might
have been secrets but I didn't see
anything so I'm gonna guess no it would
have been here yeah I was looking but I
didn't see secrets here secret was
series here we got secret I don't think
the Seekers here you don't know that I
think I do I'm looking around house
nothing no this is where you would put
the coin maybe we haven't had the drug
maybe we haven't had the chance to get
going yet okay ow
what you can't duck under it god no not
like this made it I'm the best there's a
secret here I'm smelling it out no I'm
sniffing it if i go here i hello so you
gotta like wow it's it's easy it's easy
watch this easy once this watch me watch
me watch how i do watch how I do watch
watch watch watch oh no don't look at me
don't look at me that's how I do you see
how I do like oh [ __ ] you know and how
like that now like that sweet little
baby no I like that how I do watch how I
do I tell ya see you see you see I will
get that fun for you wait I just
[Music]
[Laughter]
goddamnit
maybe if I do it again it'll hiding no
one will ever find me again is the
button really just a 5u I think it is
god damn you [ __ ] you bun you get up
there and trigger the thing and then do
it while it's lifting does it just come
back down there's yeah it appears and
raises that slowly though right here
that's how you jump over jump over here
drop you got drop off that yeah drop off
that little ledge I got you almost and
then I'll go press the button you
alright alright hurry Bob I thought you
made it oh God on my screen you run
there no I wasn't Bob drop off a little
more I don't know man wait this is
Wade's idea which automatically I'm like
why are we doing this I'm gonna make it
guys here we go can you go up and over
no you can't over I have no I can I do
this
no softer go down well we don't have the
coin anyway so I don't think it matters
canon what makes the candidates as soon
as you can see that's that's all it
takes
[ __ ] should I end this please God all
right all right
coins in this level just bought the
coins here okay there it is oh yeah
uh-huh
I don't see it hey oh hey is this one of
those where you just got to go under oh
no you can't go under it
Oh watch out watch out that was not me
that was you I don't know what the
button did oh no don't do that the
button makes it possible
sweet sweet please here we go this time
in the pocket oh I'm here it nailed it
nailed it I nailed it wait I see you
teleporter I'm going in the teleporter
it's gonna teleport it's not a
teleporter what sparkly it's something
all right
oh dear well I'm dead do I need to push
the book push the button I already
pushed it to the right
oh wait I see it I see it with my eyes I
see the solution it's so obvious it
should have been so obvious to me I see
it I see it you guys are blind but I see
I don't Shoom Shoom Shoom me Shuma see
I'm down here now
how the [ __ ] did you do that it's a
teleporter you gotta gotta get the snow
man all right what about the bucket of
ice water what should I see the bucket
of blood this yeah what is that
no thanks bud it's nothing does anything
happen if I go up in this middle
passageway to the left here no no none
of us have tried it weird Marco do we
lose I'm right next to you okay
don't know how you didn't see me how I
died don't wait don't
[Music]
[Laughter]
oh god damn it you know I feel like it
would be easier without you to here
screwing me I just feel like we should
be different trap level what what what
no just wait wait wait I'm stuck I'm
stuck
god damn it I hate this game all right
this is gonna be a slow one well
I have it I have it I have it guys I
have it if you just come away come oh
wait guys I can do it just give me a
chance all right
I've already been to the exit like three
times this week you're a liar is what
you are I'm so sad oh my god I can't
believe didn't help my case no I found
it I've got it I've got it how do you
got the solution show me show me daddy I
will show you how me lay down and get
scared
oh all right marks are coming I'm coming
mark just explain to me you're clearly
never gonna get back you just jump over
and over and over and over it I got this
tip no yep
I don't got this you can reset by going
back the yeah you got it you got it you
got this wait don't kill me don't get
bleep it's coming it's coming
don't wait don't wait
the mark mark mark I'm down here down
here oh I made it into the water daddy
no no no I'm not gonna make remember me
I was an ice cube I do that usually
youuuu met you you know what that's my
fault but I feel like infinite payback
still wouldn't be enough for Wade in the
other level we would die less if we were
playing apex legends oh you died there
oh [ __ ] coming all right mark please God
I just got a no it's impossible there's
no way I think you don't need to jump
why wouldn't you need a jump no on the
second one when you get it on you land
on the platform on the left I did you -
through and then use your easier speared
air jump oh this part you far I'm in the
woods I'm in the woods I mean no I mean
no no no I'll go this way
screw you I'm going this way it's
probably easier it is Oh
see yeah that's not like okay so that's
just a death tube okay go ahead
I'm here don't kill me I just wanna die
[ __ ] I'm not going to you you think the
teleporters the only way go wait said he
was in the woods no that's not the only
way to go I don't believe you but then I
found the real teleporter that was all
me but watch watch you see here where I
am
yeah you Sheila oh yeah you do oh you
can't get back up mark don't [ __ ] this
you sure dude you did that you were the
one who did that to me much easier and
more less time-consuming it's we should
be doing that though Bob it doesn't
matter nothing matters and doesn't
matter
oh my god I had it oh my god I had it no
guys I had it you probably don't believe
me but I had it I had it hang on all
right guys only a few more levels in
this one no no x over x over what the
[ __ ] holy [ __ ] oh yeah we gotta do the
boss fight oh [ __ ] okay that's the gun
wait don't get hit by those wait your
own gun it's like we're playing the
Icarus game so they didn't even have
spikes or nothin I done no way died died
mark wondering why is such a big deal oh
this might be a big deal oh that's
something that you can be whoa please
sing that every time future how many
lives doing it oh wait no wait look at
the bottom look at the bottom
something's happening here we go here we
go you ready get it whoa
getting closer yeah
Superman don't die Wade yeah Wade
[ __ ] I'm sorry come here it's not our
fault blamed Wade jump on my head I
don't think we won no we gotta hit him
multiple times guys that's not what you
want to see I call dibs on the back I'll
stay in the back platform I'll be right
here easy easy easy
Oh Bob gah whoo hey guys it's almost
time get ready
oh [ __ ] it's time for that [ __ ] hit him
guys guys
did we hit him I think we tinct him okay
good that's all that matters he's so
tinct he's really tipped off guys easy
easy easy easy no problem no problem
nobody easy all right
problem wait really don't blame me for
my dad big spike pillows are coming
they're gonna be fast you're right you
right hit me
it doesn't do it I can still die no no
I've learned my lesson
that's no that's a no that's a no no no
no you don't even know where the secret
is seven seven no I don't know funny
about that I'm not in seven I'm out
Maxim
[Music]
you